الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله
اكبر اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم شهدان فلسطينيان اثناء
تنفيذهما عمليه اطلاق نار على مستوطنه في
طول كرن حماس تبنت العمليه وقالت ان
المقاومه فرضت قواعد اشتباك جديده تزامن
ذلك مع اشتباك عنيفه في مخيم طول كرم ادت
الى اصابه خمسه جنود
اسرائيليين في التطورات في السودان الجيش
قصف بالطائرات المسيره والمدفعيه الثقيله
اهدافا تابعه للدعم السريع في مناطقه عده
في العاصمه الخرطوم في المقابل قصفت قوات
الدعم السريع مناطق شماليه ام درمان اسفرت
عن سقوط قتلى وجرحه من
المدنيين سلطات اذربيجان تعتقل زعيم ارمن
اقليم كارباخ في وقت اكدت فيه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه انها ستدعم ارمينيا لا سما في
الشق الانساني في حين قاطع الرئيس
الاذربيجاني اجتماع غرناطه احتجاجا على ما
وصفه بالانحياز الاوروبي لارمينيا
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم يمنح الملف
المشترك بين المغرب واسبانيا والبرتغال حق
تنظيم كاس العالم 2030 وبذلك سيصبح المغرب
ثاني بلد عربي يستضيف الحدث المونديالي
بعد البطوله التي اقيمت في دوله قطر العام
الماضي الى
اللقاء